kim kardashian is
back home the reality star returned to
la on tuesday
after visiting her husband kanye west in
wyoming the day before
kim flew back home alone and was spotted
after her plane touched down in los
angeles tmz reports that kanye stayed in
cody wyoming where he's been living
and recording music i feel like we are
so blessed to have the best support
system and the best
family to really just support each other
no matter what we're going through of
course kim's return to la comes a day
after she
and kanye reunited for the first time
since his controversial political rally
in south carolina earlier this month and
that storm of
since-deleted tweets about his wife i
always believe and trust in him that he
will
always eventually explain himself so i
know what he really means when he says
something and i know that people will
too at some point a source previously
told et
kim flew to cody wyoming monday to see
kanye after
weeks of trying to get a hold of him and
that the meeting was
extremely emotional adding that kim is
still very upset with kanye but
knows she needs to focus on him getting
better and plans to do whatever she can
to get him the help he needs
i've seen him go through a lot i always
know his heart
while the skimmed designer was in
wyoming the two were seen having what
appeared to be an intense conversation
in the car
where kim seemed to be crying their
tear-filled reunion came just one day
after yay made a public apology to his
wife
on twitter for airing out their private
issues in public
even if my wife were to divorce me after
this speech
she brought north into the world even
when i didn't want to
kanye said in his apology quote i did
not cover her like she has covered me
to kim i want to say i know i hurt you
please forgive me
thank you for always being there for me
i mean
we have different views sometimes but
that's my husband you know
meanwhile a source told e.t kim and the
fam are happy the 43 year old apologized
but their main concern making sure he
gets help
kanye said hurtful things to kim and the
family and in time that will heal
but kanye's health is priority in life
what i've learned is you just kind of
have to go with it
of course all of this comes after kanye
delivered an emotional speech at his
presidential rally earlier this month
where he revealed he and kim talked
about having an abortion
when she was pregnant with her first
child north
she stood up and she protected that
child he later claimed on twitter that
the reality star and her mom kris jenner
were trying to get a doctor to lock him
up he's just the most
genuine person and you know he might say
things that
might get misinterpreted and people
don't see the context behind it
and as we all know kanye has been vocal
about his struggles with bipolar
disorder
in the past there's some cases of
bipolar where people
go low i'm i'm one that uh goes high
and last wednesday kim released a
statement on instagram asking the public
to show
compassion and empathy
you